what's up you guys original grain i'm
here to talk to you about original grain
my brother and i it's the last chance to
get stuff for father's day and we have
the perfect gift for every dad um
they're gonna sell out of the stuff all
the inventory before father's day so
make sure you get them early go to
original originalgrain.com
lifeline for 30 off i got the glasses on
i love these glasses i wear them while
i'm driving and i'm very cool with my
you know i got the big i got the i'm
sitting in the bloody guts and i got
this and then i have a really cool like
thick watch here and this one came with
a guitar pick i'm not very musical but
look though if your dad is like a guitar
if he's a strummer he's got the watch
you could tell what time it is and he's
also playing my ring look at my wing
they got wedding rings uh and every
watch that they sell they plant a tree
so if you make a purchase not only are
you a good person for father's day uh
getting a gift or even something for
yourself you're also a good person for
the environment and so far they've
planted over half a million trees um and
they're
all made from unique materials for
almost a decade there's over twenty
thousand five star reviews
okay so many so be one of those people
and uh go to originalgrain.com
lifeline for 30 off use code lifeline at
original crane originalgrain.com
lifeline to get 30 off site wide that's
everything the glasses the watch all of
that rings um we also make watches from
other sustainable materials like 100
recycled ocean plastic reclaimed
military ammo wood crate so you know
you're a good person if you get stuff
from here so that's code lifeline at
originalgrain.com lifeline to get 30 off
site-wide get your father's day gift
taken care of today
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
you know go get a job as
an accountant
you're not coming to los angeles
california
[ __ ] thank you no that was though
because we were doing american idol i
know but i was just doing it well you
wouldn't turn british but i did a
british guy wouldn't sing [ __ ] link
what is it nothing in park uh limp
biscuits
biscuit worst band name ever lymph
biscuit bias biscuit was the [ __ ] in
1999 so was it 99 were they though
yeah they were the [ __ ] dude that was
exactly what the world needed oh yeah
yeah okay like exactly like think about
the music now where he's like i did all
for the nookie like now that's literally
every song is basically saying i think
that the world didn't need it though
ever
no limp biscuit wasn't good
i love fred durst and that's it okay as
a man on earth yeah as a person too you
know he directed a movie that i saw
okay it's called the fanatic and it
stars my main man
the one and only greatest man alive john
travolta um john travolta is uh
can be a very bad actor and a very good
actor
except
that's totally true except the first
part no he's he's been bad so much when
was he ever bad
okay well he was bad in
uh
that
i believe he was bad in that o.j i knew
you're gonna say that he's the only good
thing in that no dude yep no he was so
bad the whole thing is bad he's a
standout good
very bad and he's very bad no and he
adds to the bad news no no when a thing
is that bad and someone's being that
ludicrous and like over-the-top and fun
to watch they're the only good thing
i i i agree with that logic but this
time it was not like that i don't know
dude he like made he just like made
faces for no reason like like robert
shapiro wasn't like that at all yeah he
was so low-key and chill in the box in
the lawyer's box
but john was like nah what about gotti
oh
what about that other one where he's the
guy who is the fraud that has a boat
the [ __ ] i saw that i don't know what
the [ __ ] it was called probably
something like fastlane oh he does the
thing nick cage does which is like
movies pre-financed by a foreign country
because the person's still famous there
oh yeah they get like 20 million dollars
before they even roll a single
shot i do those movies nope i just
haven't done any yet but i i'm saying i
do those movies if you're out there
finland or whatever the [ __ ] you want me
to do some [ __ ] no it's like germany
like these people are still oh yeah i'm
out there
apparently i'm big in uh
uh what's the german berlin
you're big in berlin that's what i hear
so let's go
berlin's [ __ ] great well there's only
like nine million people in all of
germany though right something like that
i don't know i have no idea either i
just say [ __ ] but that doesn't make it
less important mine's [ __ ] cool no i
know but i'm like if you're famous it's
easy to be famous in germany is what i'm
saying no that's a bad logic that is a
bad logic anyways thank you for all of
all of you guys out there i really
appreciate you guys you're so great do
they like you more because you could you
do when you do it i don't know why they
like me honestly me neither i don't look
german at all right i look very italian
and also you don't look that italian i
look italian i look italian you don't
look that attitude do i look greek i
look greek you look a little greek you
look like uh
careful now though no i'm like
scandinavian because you're so you're so
pale i do look scandinavian yeah yeah
but i'm italian and i'll tell you this
much dude elephant in the room i got it
i'm a little bit more tan right
we should mention it let's see hang on
so i'm a little bit more tan um first of
all you couldn't look more like a
birdies with those glasses on in the hat
i know he didn't wear a hat in the
[ __ ] movie but
oh you're a little more tan yep how'd
that happen i was outside it was eric
griffin's wedding oh eric griffin got
married yep hell yeah yep and uh to that
girl he's been with for a long time
right yeah well
you know a new girl yeah yeah it would
be
very good no not a new girl no yeah the
girl that he's been with congratulations
eric i love you eric griffin i don't
like comics you know you don't like
comments uh he's one of the few that i
truly really love very much there's
something very cool about him his energy
is amazing he's a great guy too yeah
just [ __ ] good dude yeah it was
really special to see him get married um
and uh it was a nice reception and uh
but elephant in the room you know i just
had to address it that i am obviously
very i'm a lot more ten than i am
because you were at the wedding i was
outside yeah i was outside dude and i
turned i was at the i was
i was like let me get the crystal was
like where you want to sit i was like
let's sit over there at the end because
i didn't want to be in the front i
didn't want to be you know in the back
so the middle is great you know so i
we go and i say keep going we'll go to
the end so we're at the end okay and the
outside of the thing i got the last
chair in the middle i'm in the middle
but i got the last chair
okay you know what i'm saying yeah on
the outside right so so then
um
i get this [ __ ]
uh it goes you know the music happens
and then the people start walking the
music happens yeah okay because i don't
know it's not the bride music yet it's
just beautiful
music yeah yeah yeah it makes you cry
you in the mood yeah oh the mood bro i
thank god i had sunglasses on you cry
dude
i i it's not even like i'm like
it's it's unfair like i don't know if
it's i think it's a lot is it because of
calvin and then a lot is because i do
like bro i did therapy the other day and
legitimately cried the whole [ __ ]
time and then i'm just crying a lot more
lately i cry it's a lot but you're just
turning into dad i guess i know dude
i haven't caught that [ __ ] wind yet i
don't cry that much i caught it hard the
past two years man like i definitely
don't cry at weddings i only cry at
weddings because i don't want to [ __ ]
be there yeah i'm so miserable at
weddings and here's the other thing dude
i actually had a good time at his
wedding
i know well weddings are a lot of them
are horrible but this one was great
anyway so
i'm at the outside of the thing and
the music starts and violins are just
like [ __ ] violins you know they just
make you
that's why they're going to pull it out
get you emotive emoji i know i know so
uh he comes walking in with his mom and
i'm just like forget it that's cute yeah
and uh and i i take my chair and i'm
like i got the outside chair i can just
literally just kind of like turn it oh
because everyone's like this
yeah yeah yeah that's like good [ __ ] so
you did that i just go i literally you
know it was like this so i go like this
and i'm like on the outside yeah yeah
and i'm doing it and and kristen is next
to me on this side and she's just like
this and she looks back at me she's like
you can't have your chair like that and
i was like oh really i guess it messed
up the [ __ ] thing and she was like
yeah you gotta put it regular i was like
i just figured i was on the outside or
whatever it didn't affect anybody though
well it might even matter maybe in
pictures it was gonna look bad i think
she was saying i think it was okay what
you did well whatever but i i i you know
i acquiesced and i didn't want i hope i
didn't ruin his wedding but it was
beautiful no i don't think you did um
yeah so i don't know and i'm nauseous
today
whoo why are you nauseous woke up two
burgers ate two burgers last night why'd
you do that
one didn't
one didn't have the bun on it so i
thought it was okay such an idiot hey
dude i ate a burger in and out dude we
wanted to go to in and out chris was
like let's go to in and out didn't want
to go what time
10 30. too late
dude didn't want to go uh it was i
wanted to go she was like let's go to in
and out and i was like all right cool
let's go
and then uh
didn't want to go but then we went on a
way to in and out she goes like ooh go
there points to taco bell
i'm pissed
well yeah i don't want to go to podcast
i don't want to go to taco bell and
she's like well come on go talk about i
was like i didn't want to go to in-n-out
but like can we like compromise and she
was like oh fine and i was like no you
know what dude i was like let's do this
we'll go to taco bell for you and then
we'll go to in and out you went to both
you guys are [ __ ] disgusting i didn't
go i didn't eat both she ate both no no
no no no we keep both but just going to
both yeah like it's like a disgusting
parade but taco bell is disgusting as
[ __ ] and in and out is like okay but
then if you eat two of them it's
disgusting as [ __ ] also with the cheese
fries that i ate oh you you guys had an
impromptu disgusting parade it was a
smorgasbord dude i thought we're gonna
eat together she ate in the car and then
we went home and then i [ __ ] she went
to bed and i was sitting there eating a
[ __ ] eating eating uh burgers
watching a game stop a documentary on
the on the gamestop stop uh
travesty that happened in the [ __ ]
thing so dude i was a piece of [ __ ] just
eating that stuff
fat
yeah it was fat as [ __ ] yeah watching a
game stop documentary yeah that's anyway
but it was uh it was good dude gamestop
you know i should we should have got in
on that huh
we really should have gotten on imagine
how much [ __ ] loaded cash would have
what you know
imagine how much loaded cash we'd have
blue chips dude yeah the movie i
remember the movie dude who's in it shaq
who else is in it [ __ ] dude
i don't know alan iverson wow that went
from so happy to christian
no no no uh uh anthony
yeah yeah yeah little penny
penny penny hardaway and [ __ ] uh
nick nolte nick nolte on your ass right
no he's the coach yeah nick nolte on
your ass uh william friedkin directed it
on your ass
dude shaquille o'neal on your ass is in
it i already said that penny hard away
on your asses
the worst reviewer
welcome to on your ass with leonard
martin yeah dude uh i saw it in the
theaters with dad when it came out
that's what early oh yeah why cause you
like basketball i can't imagine dad
going to the movie theater to watch blue
chips
the guy that directed the exorcist and
french connection is just like it's just
a [ __ ] on your ass movie it's just
that everybody's french connection blue
chips yeah dude he's mixing it up
gene hackman
other good actors in the exorcist and
then shaquille o'neal but nick nolte on
your ass dude i had a kid i had a kid
when i was in high school and he would
say like chuck gilly o'neill yeah and
they made me mad and it made me mad jack
gillian remember when you would come
into my room late at night and do
impressions of all the different guys
yeah in my high school yeah that was
gary o'neil that was derek right derek
and he would go like this john kemp john
kemp dude this pissed me off so much man
this pissed me off so much he goes like
this we're talking about basketball
players he was like john kemp no john
kemp he is the most entertaining player
in the nba that's what he said and i was
just like dude the fact that like he
thought of that already and then used it
for this conversation i didn't like the
[ __ ] methodical [ __ ] that he did you
know what's interesting about that if
somebody said that now i'd be like oh
you just watched some stupid youtube
yeah it's like 11 minutes but back then
he thought of that [ __ ] on his own he
went through it he got it or like his
dad or uncle told him that yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah definitely but it sounds
like you're saying it sounds like he was
saying
john kemp john kemp and chuck de leon
but it's shawn kemp oh i know and it's
shaquille o'neal and he was one of the
most entertaining players in the nba at
the time yeah jack willie o'neill was
one of the [ __ ] tallest jamiroquai
o'neill
jamiroquai walls and [ __ ]
uh what's that song
uh the jamiroquai song yeah
oh no
it's so good though remember the video
what's the name of it uh
yeah it was good dude all right um
thank you
yeah let's do it
[Music]
what we got
hi kristin matt my name is cassie
so nervous but i'll relax
i'm calling in first to say love you
both uh i'm a baby
and a log cabin member
um
i'm here in savannah georgia and i'm
calling to ask you both about
how to propose to my boyfriend
three months pregnant he's the greatest
guy i've ever met and i want to do
something special and big and wow him
and i know him well but i don't know
what guys want when it comes to a
proposal whether
i'm stealing his thunder if a woman were
to propose to you
wow how would you guys expect it to go
down would you want it to be funny or
over the top or very very public
maybe i do it at chris's show in
savannah here on october 22nd wow
goodbye i'm doing it
um but i would love to hear your
thoughts and maybe chris you could tell
us how you proposed to kristin um
that would be cool to hear whoa okay
you're awesome thank you bye
you're awesome even though that was like
that question was like slanted towards
you i think she's awesome even though
she did that okay well yeah that's okay
to think that she's awesome even though
she did that you didn't even know you
know what she scented it so hard towards
you why don't you [ __ ] take me
so dude first of all
well congratulations she said she's
three months pregnant right oh really
that's what she said right okay yes yeah
um
i i
have never known
a woman that has
proposed to a man uh personally have you
i bet i have i just didn't know that i'm
saying like yeah yeah maybe but like
i've heard about it many times well i've
heard about it
i i don't know i don't know i've never
known about it though um that would be
good though definitely do it yeah [ __ ]
it why do you think i think that because
like oh i get i guess there's so much
stress on the guy to get it right
anything she does is going to be [ __ ]
fine but yeah there's no version of him
that would be like you know i wish she
really did it like this it would have
been so much that's true that's just
like anything you do the only thing that
is possible is that if he's like
you've got the macho he's like she's
nothing and he's like i just wish you
let me do it yeah yeah yeah yeah but i
do that's what i wonder i wonder if but
it sounds like they have the kind of
relationship if you think she doesn't
feel like an insane person barring that
it's like you're almost doing him a
favor i think but if she's three months
pregnant maybe her brain is doing some
crazy [ __ ] but i would also suggest the
one thing i do know for sure don't do
public that's never good no you know
what you should do i i she asked i think
she hit it on the head i think it should
be light and fun
if it's a dude yeah if you're doing like
really romantic [ __ ] and pulling out all
the stops yeah that guy's going to feel
emasculated i think maybe but i don't
know the guy yeah but like even if he
isn't though i think a guy would
appreciate it lighter a little humor and
lighter stuff yeah like yeah like
remember in the remember in the [ __ ]
um
uh goodwill hunting when uh ra what's
the robin williams is like it's not your
fault yeah and matt damon is like nice i
i know yeah
he's like it's not your fault he's like
yeah it's not your fault he's like dude
i know that like that's
where a guy is if
they're they're always have that much
emotion right behind the emotion and
he's not going to want to [ __ ] crack
hard like i felt like a [ __ ] when i was
crying at eric's wedding i got to be
good with that right that's going to be
my thing no that's like a place where
people cry i know but i'm saying
if you do it in a lighter way it's less
like that and the guy is less i don't
you know i don't i i don't because if a
chick was in the [ __ ] goodwill
hunting thing and robin williams was
like it's not your fault a girl would be
like
i'm so glad that somebody actually said
and
that should be five hours long so what
i'm saying is right sit deeper and it's
fine but what i'm saying is
keep it
nice
jovial hey how's it going want to go to
starbucks by the way
what's this and he goes a ring and he
say it's yours and then you say yeah by
the way also do you want to marry me and
then say here's your macchiato
spin out terrible idea
do not do that but i agree about the
lightness uh
uh yeah i also think the therapy with
the woman would be shorter because he'd
say it's not your fault and then
there's no like barrier so the barrier
of him being like no i know it makes it
take longer i don't know
like there's no barriers so it's
instantly like the water works yeah but
water works for so long right because
not just because you know oh i see
because women crash along and then they
talk so much
deeper but fine state right yeah so um
yeah and congratulations you know what i
i don't i've never had people come up
and uh on stage and the guy's obviously
not a fan of mine because he doesn't
watch anything i do because of course
you would never [ __ ] do this so
thanks a lot guys but um
but uh she i think that she i've never
had anyone uh do
ask
them to marry me that would be wild if i
had a female ask a man you know i think
men probably are like nah that's my job
but then if it actually happens it's
like
i'm i'm sitting at my show sorry i
didn't say that oh no
the main part yeah she said yeah but she
said that i know but you didn't say i
know because i i got ahead of myself
that would be crazy i don't know i know
comedians have done that and stuff like
joe croy probably does it every [ __ ]
he doesn't probably act breaks and does
it but like uh guys
you know yeah before we go for our third
act break
i feel like that guy's always doing
different [ __ ] here but thank you boys
to men now we're doing it's like people
are like can you talk about your son um
so uh
so yeah so i just um i don't know if i
would ever do that on my on my show i
always felt like the act was the act and
comedians that did that it's like it's
nice and it's sweet i guess it is nice
they incorporate you like facilitate
yeah you'll be like guys the guy come up
oh i gotta yeah i guess that's how it
would be i don't know i've never done it
but nah that's not good yeah i don't
think that's good either yeah don't do
it not public yeah yeah just that's my
only keep it light keep it nice
keep making dinner at home
very it could be very sweet at home or
go to a place where you might have gone
on like your first date if it's private
some like look out spot some like
romantic spot as
loki and then bust it as for me kristen
said she didn't want to do she didn't
want to make a big deal about it at all
like she was like literally i just want
you to like roll over when we're gonna
go to sleep and do it i was like really
and she was like yeah i was like okay
and then i i did it and i was in a a
like a hoodie it was just some i was so
nervous you know i was in a hoodie and
then and like pant like pajamas and she
and i said come outside i went outside
and i asked her in on the patio and then
she was and then
i did it and then whenever she told the
story she was like yeah he did it in
pajamas it was really cute and then i
felt like man maybe they don't like they
think that i'm being like not and so
then i redid it well you did yeah i
redid it wow i read that [ __ ]
mulligan i'm asking i redid it because
she said no the second time i redid it
and i did it with calvin
and um in front of her friends when we
were taking pictures for her friend i
think her friends were they were taking
pictures or something for something
which one did she like more
of the
of
friends
marriage proposal i guess the second one
i don't i don't know i did it twice
though you get two two bang for your
buck more bang for your buck so all
right anyway uh good luck and
congratulations on the pregnancy that's
[ __ ] awesome
[Music]
let's go
hey mark hey chris my name's lewis i'm
from the uk i'm 24. apologies for the
unnamed shirt i'm just chilling at home
um i love the podcast i love
congratulations what's like every
episode i love it anyway my question is
right
so i'm on a career path i know what i
want to do
um but i just love going out and
partying and chilling with my friends
and having a good time
so my question is like how do i get off
the path
of going out every weekend
and just ruining my life
i love it and just focus on that career
goal like how do you just focus on it
probably a simple answer but i'd love to
hear your guys opinion thank you peace
out guys oh [ __ ] yeah dude he's a dick
you know what he's addicted to the life
dude he's addicted to the life that is
so [ __ ] ill you got to get over that
though dude but he's addicted to the
life dude and he [ __ ] goes out bro
that i guarantee you you see him look at
his face he was hurting all night that
was in the morning he had a hair coming
off of his chin he'd even redo the video
and he probably didn't see it he's so
hungover but my point is dude he is
addicted to the life that guy
more than like i would say
what percentage of the time are your
hands below your shoulders
oh geez 98 nine yeah yeah this guy's
probably
half and half
half and half
i mean that guy bro half above him oh
man
that guy's addicted to the life bro i
think though his [ __ ] [ __ ] is
fifteen percent of the time right yeah
oh sorry
eighty-five percent above dude
to the life right here the strong
shoulder muscles and then [ __ ] yeah a
dick
one that still counts
with the drinks you have just one count
dude addicted to it [ __ ] coke molly
still up dude 15
dude and from the time 11 30 to 2 a.m
45 percent of the time it's like this
wow yes getting his dick suck his uk
i love it
so my shirt ain't on that but like holy
[ __ ] i'm about to pass off on time
i'm about to boss off i'm about to empty
me nuts on time why do british guys when
you do them sound a little bit like
kermit
what's up with that i want to come over
to my lily pad and [ __ ] finish it off
in the back
she's just like your hands are above
your head a lot
uh he did say weekend though so like
he's burning it on the weekends and then
during the week he means wednesday
through the
the advice
is
keep it on the weekends and have it be
something to look forward to monday to
friday focus on the [ __ ] as you call
him career goals also what do you say
he's 24 years old
is that what he said he's young as
[ __ ] [ __ ] wow dude that [ __ ] sweet
life is catching up to him he looks
[ __ ] 29 but that [ __ ] will slow down
the desire to be [ __ ] dude and be
[ __ ] up all the time will will burn
out on its own but just keep it to a
minimum in the sense that keep it on the
days that it's supposed to be for
burning away on the weekends on the
weekdays you keep it about the career
this is like a [ __ ] state he's like
you know he's like he's like a new york
if this was he's in america he'd be like
a new york stock dude stop yeah change
like a [ __ ] wall street dude that's
what we want though we want the hard
work during the week
and then on the weekends just burning it
out and then one day coming in like a
zombie but by friday you feel kind of
healthier and refreshed for the [ __ ]
weekend you're living for the weekend
like [ __ ] every other song says but
he he says he knows what he wants to do
so maybe he likes his job too i really
wonder what his job is i wish he said
yeah
who's like what's your job he's just
like
right yeah well then that's gonna kind
of i love throwing burgers at doors
what's with you and things being
why do you insist that they throw the
food at the door they don't give a [ __ ]
why drive by they go what happened to
you
with doordash why do you insist that
that's true i don't use it
you don't even know postmates is the
worst you literally don't even know i
don't know no i saw memes
dude the worst way to learn [ __ ]
i understand i saw memes um dude no
postmates is the worst dude no
not they're the same thing they'll bring
the food to your [ __ ] door bro
they deliver it in wrong places and i go
nuts i actually like not at your door
where do they go oh bro they don't even
put it at a door sometimes so where did
they where do they put it like
i [ __ ] got out once it was like on
someone's lawn they don't give a [ __ ]
dude they put it in one of those [ __ ]
tree holes at the keebler i was leaving
living you got shitty shitty shitty door
dashers and postmates bro do you think
and no knock dude i mean it's hard out
there you got to get hard getting a job
but like people who do ubereats they
don't want to be doing ubereats so
they're just like
you know what i mean well they're not
going to be doing it long if they do
that [ __ ] they're going to complain and
they won't be able to do it anymore bro
and then i try not to [ __ ] complain
and i don't want to [ __ ] i i want to
still tip them but it's like i try real
hard not to do that too yeah i don't
have to do a lot do you just do it right
some and then you go call them and then
they're like i don't actually i'm like
where's my food and you see the picture
you know they leave it with the picture
oh yeah yeah and you're like this is not
a place i've seen wow weird that's not
that's never happened it's not a place
i've seen i went up and down the last
one i went up and down my street i
looked at every place oh the food was
not there oh bro i was so mad i ordered
it again you don't know where the same
thing i ordered again
okay
i i go downstairs
when the second time comes they're both
there
yeah
they're both there
the [ __ ] i was so mad i ate them both i
ate them both so fat like [ __ ] the next
day yeah
it was two salmon that's kind of a
mystery case yeah it was annoying as
[ __ ] anyway very weird you wanna do
another one
hey matt and chris love the show i'm
gonna cut to the point because i've made
this video so many times and i keep
screwing it up
i recently discovered that my husband
chews on his own dead skin and just
disgusts me his hands were peeling
he was biting it off chewing on it
between his teeth two two two spit do it
again
um he also if he has a cut he licks the
blood and says he's putting it back in
his body
it very much grosses me out i mean
i told him it's disgusting how to do it
in front of our children
and he said that it's normal everybody
does it
and basically that i'm being
dramatic i guess
so i'd like to know is it normal does
everybody do it is it a guy thing or is
it disgusting and how do i get this out
of my brain to save my marriage
thanks guys
uh it's not a guy thing unless they're
under six years old yeah it's definitely
not normal no that's not it's completely
abnormal yeah and i would say get a
divorce i would say get a divorce that's
pretty harsh yeah but get a divorce that
is it would teach him a lesson not okay
be harsh why is he trying to gaslight
you about it to me like it's totally
normal everybody does it like what like
you're not it thinks it is like you're
not alive in the world why does he think
that no one does that maybe i don't know
there's [ __ ] reddit groups you know
what i mean
i guarantee there's a reddit group uh
[ __ ] skin chewers yeah but they're
not normal members of society out in the
world
this is like a [ __ ] stephen king
that's disgusting dude that is not only
not normal that is
[ __ ] disgusting uh
it's it's gross i i don't find it that
disgusting i would i would borderline
throw up if someone did that in front of
me eating their own chewing on their own
dead skin not even eating it digesting
it is one thing just like getting it
down and [ __ ] colored a whole other
thing is just like like it's gum well i
don't think she said he swallows it
that's even worse he should swallow it
he's chewing on it that's pretty weird
dude maybe you know what honestly look
at him and be like eat mine too i'm your
wife if i have dried skin i want you to
eat a bowl of mine with milk otherwise
stop doing it it's not fair he'd
probably get a [ __ ] heart on he just
goes he's got a ringer
get the get the two percent bra
yeah just with the [ __ ]
dead skin
oh god yeah yeah i mean it's disgusting
just thinking about it makes you want to
[ __ ] throw up um i'll tell you
something okay putting blood back in
your body by yeah licking it is not a
thing that's not well no it doesn't work
obviously he's just making stuff up that
guy's a vampire he's just totally making
stuff i'm putting it back in my body i'm
eating my skin because i'm putting it
back in my body i'm eating my [ __ ]
because i'm putting it back in my body
yeah it's not in your body because it's
supposed to not be in your body maybe
the bleeding thing also dude
how many cuts is this guy having like
what does that mean
i'm [ __ ] 42. i have zero cuts i
haven't had a cut for years he's just
constantly walking through his [ __ ]
skinning his knee and [ __ ] always
constantly walking through rose bushes
what's going on with this rose bush this
is basically the advice um just you he
that guy that's so gross does he do it
out he's got to stop don't you know what
here's the advice
don't do it around the kids or me yeah
that's the do it in private if you want
to do it you're not hurting anyone
don't do it around me and don't let him
even go an inch further with the oh it's
normal everyone does it they do not do
it guys do not do that listen to me no
one does that besides [ __ ] serial
killers eating your skin is not normal
that's crystallized said it so just show
them that dude
eating your skin and drinking your blood
it's not normal yeah vote for me yeah
message paid for by vampires yeah do not
do not let them you really want this cr
you really want crystalline as mayor he
says drinking drinking blood and eating
skin isn't good paid for by the vampire
association paid for by her husband yeah
yeah he's there yeah just like he's
against you hello hello wife why is he
serious have you been eating does he
kill people also have you been eating
your blood again no what makes you ask
that collar is so [ __ ] high skin
banging off you have skin hanging off of
that's frosted flakes
so bad okay
adamandeve.com
with all the bad news about prices these
days it's nice to know that adam and eve
is still offering the best deal at
adamandeve.com get 50 off and free
shipping that's 50
off an adventurous toy
slippery lube or almost
anything you desire uh okay our podcast
listeners will get 50 off almost every
every item um just use code lifeline at
checkout and you'll get 50 off and
what
free
shipping right so it doesn't matter what
you choose it'll all be packaged and
sent completely discreet so you don't
have to worry about you know something
very cool we're sex positive on this
show but like you know if you if you
want to get a dildo to your house and
you don't want people to know it then
very discreet packaging adamandeve.com
uh you save money on gas you don't have
to go to the thing
uh movies and date night dinners out um
but this is the item that will continue
to save you money even after you
purchase it deliver tons of fun and
satisfaction good point honestly boo
yeah so go to adamandeve.com select any
one item use code lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e
and this is a this is an exclusive offer
to uh specific to this podcast so be
sure to support our show and use the
code lifeline to get you not just the 50
off but also the 100 percent free
shipping code lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now code lifeline
hey guys so relax
bring out all this great content i love
your work and a big fan here
so i've had this skate a few weeks ago
um we went to a wine bar ended up
drinking laughing having a really good
time you know one of what if he's gonna
be doing dates
and then the check arrives and
we both put out our credit cards
and she looks at me and says should i
put my credit card
and i'm like
do whatever you feel like that was my
honest response oh boy honestly and then
the waitress approaches and she
elegantly kind of takes her card back
because she likes you
and pushes her at the end of the day i
was like ah that sucks it really turned
me off you know yeah that would turn me
off too but also i wonder how uh you
guys would have handled it or if you
have any thoughts about this
piece a disguise why would that turn you
off
because
first of all this guy this guy
he i love how he is so where do you
think he's from
eastern like
like
wherever he's from he's so from there i
think he's [ __ ] algerian that he's
like
he i just speak my mind like i say do
whatever you feel like and he was
probably like this guy like just i get
the sense that this guy was just like i
don't um
i don't i would love to pay because i am
a member i don't want to make you feel
uncomfortable yeah like that's probably
what's going on his head so he was just
like do whatever you like and then she
took it as
oh
the the problem with that is
he's putting it on her yeah so he's
putting two things on her
that and also
the he's not paying as the man which i
understand that's traditional it doesn't
have always had to be that way it's fine
if you want to go dutch but he [ __ ] up
by speaking his mind this is one of
those times where
he should have just said i got it yeah
don't worry about it yes and he didn't
do that and that made it a little more
awkward
so now when she took and here's why it
turns me off
so my instinct okay one of the i by the
way i would always pay for dinners if i
was on a date like i just that that
would be my go-to right yeah that's not
you didn't say the right thing yeah
right
but i like how he was being him and i
like how he reacted to what he said he
was like that was just what i said it
was on my mind yeah if sh
but um
he i think i [ __ ] i forgot i lost my
train of thought go ahead i forgot my
trade of thought yeah i mean i
i don't know why that turned you off oh
i think that okay go ahead i it it turns
me off when i will always pay
that's it's fine if you that makes you
uncomfortable you want to do both
whatever yeah like
um
i feel like
i
a cheap person turns me off and i'm not
saying it she's being cheap because she
very well may have been like this is a
date i don't want to pay because you
know what i mean
um
and the fact that she took it out in the
first place anyway was actually
thoughtful
right yeah uh but
maybe it turned him off because i don't
know why it turned him off but for me if
somebody if i sense somebody is
cheap
it's a turn off but that doesn't mean
it's cheap you're right you're right i
could have mean a number of things
you're right the more i think about it
her asking him that is basically her
asking him what is this what are we
doing yes yes yes and yes we figured it
out together it wasn't just you and him
saying i don't know whatever you want is
like not it's deflecting the question
she's asking him what is this where are
we that's right or what what is this and
he said i don't know whatever you want
and that's like
and then even more like she could have
been saying no no this is a date i'm
taking my card back so she could have
been doing a number of things correctly
and he is not only getting it wrong by
[ __ ] not saying the right thing in
the first place but then being turned
off by the fact that she's saying no no
this is a [ __ ] date i don't think
she's saying uh i mean maybe she is but
the guy's [ __ ] so handsome i don't
think she was like oh i'm gonna get a
free drink out of this or whatever it
was right right right i mean she could
be a [ __ ] yeah if she was a hoe she
wouldn't mean to take the thing out at
all right the card out at all if she
meant if she was an actual escort yes
she would no just like no not that but
like a hoe that's just like trying to go
get free food dinners and [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does that oh you mean a hobo oh
dude have you ever been in l.a yeah
just trying to get you you mean there
are people out there who ju who go on
what otherwise appear to be dates with
people they are not interested in just
to eat yeah i don't know why he doesn't
get it okay guys back sorry against
world records just call me dude why
would they do that that's so boring and
not like 100 percent [ __ ] be like you
the other night and get taco bell dude
that that
save yourself a night because of hoes
want to be out and they want free meals
hoes want to be out and they want free
meals with and they want to be seen in
dresses and [ __ ] dude have you been in
la have you met hoes
guys i'll call you back dude i know he's
never met one hoe yes unbelievable it
was guinness book sorry i don't i don't
know anyone like this i'll be perfectly
honest i i have to i have to say i don't
know what that person is well the i'm
i'm learning now so some of them they
don't even know they're doing it they're
just like i think maybe i like them and
they're just like oh and then
eating and [ __ ] in her [ __ ] town gold
sequin dress okay bye dry dick gets in
the uber he paid for and [ __ ] hits on
the uber dude just go to [ __ ] taco
bell
get like a thing for getting we don't
want taco bell why do they want to go
and i'm sorry i'll call you back two
hours dude two hours with someone they
don't give a [ __ ] about just to eat yes
dude if they're rich or if they're
[ __ ] hands up dude that sucks those
people suck
i don't know what's up oh suck but
that's not all just literally
implied like there's some kind of like
sex involved
no this is like this is a whole boat
this is a hobo this is a hobo hoes want
free [ __ ]
hoes want free uh-huh this is the common
misconception with a hoe dude
hoes
don't necessarily [ __ ]
we don't nobody gives a [ __ ] you're
using the wrong word no no i'm changing
the lexicon you can't you're not allowed
to do that you can just make up a
meaningful award i mean i've kind of
done that over the past few years but
i'm saying someone is a no one should be
allowing you to do that because that's
just confusing
when you say
i think that's shorthand for like escort
it's like it's like if a ho okay if a
hoe is like if a girl is like if a girl
has so many like they say so many bodies
right this year if the girls if the
girls had sex with 30 guys this year and
it's [ __ ] april right and you're like
whoa yo you [ __ ] a lot you're a hoe huh
and you're like i just [ __ ] whenever i
[ __ ] a lot you know i [ __ ] yes i agree
that's not a a hoe is like i don't know
no not really and then [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] you know what i mean
nope uh it's a lot whose lie is what i'm
saying who's lying they're liars and
they're hobos
yeah okay i mean this person you're
describing acts way more like
a
a homeless person or someone who's just
completely broke that's just trying to
[ __ ] eat for free they have homes but
they're [ __ ] often paid for by dudes
like this
a girl that [ __ ] a lot is not a hoe but
my problem is that a hoe is something in
the world sure i get what you're saying
but i'm changing that
okay because escort his escort that's
what i thought you were describing
that's not what i'm describing
okay
uh anyway what the [ __ ] was this person
talking he should have said honestly
when she said when she said do you want
me to pay with my credit card too he
should have said how wet is my dick
going to get tonight
no he should have just said yes if he
wanted her to and no if he didn't want
her to that's it him saying anything
wishy-washy is a [ __ ] shitty response
no or yes that's the way to [ __ ]
answer that question because you're
answering is this a date or is this not
a [ __ ] date can i put my dick in half
hard does that work
yeah i mean that would have answered you
some questions as well then she would
and then she'll write down yeah and then
she takes it right out and it takes
right out and goes like this good then
it will be fully hard
okay you want to have heart dick pay
you will not be having sex
oh [ __ ] who does that sound like that
sounds like uh
uh
[ __ ] tony shalum and something what
is that [ __ ] i don't know man you can't
call monk
no no no i'm not monk all right cool
what's the next one let's do it baby
stud
wow
this got peaked in high school no doubt
i can't
chris big fan been listening to your
podcast since day one been to a bunch of
shows hell yeah um he's not wearing
pants matt it's been awesome to get to
know you more
um i've been living with my best friend
which has been awesome except for one
major exception
he's got into a relationship recently
and they have no boundaries they
literally spend every
second and minute together and
being his roommate it affects my life
and interferes with my life a lot and
that hasn't been great i'm just
wondering what you guys think of how i
should be dealing with that and i can
also
tell you know he's not 100 himself he's
not really taking care of himself and
you know i just want to know what a
supportive friend should do in this case
wow what a nice guy thanks a lot
well great out of hair too handsome dude
nice low angle looking strong yeah
um
i don't know dude i think
definitely bringing up with them i mean
this is
your home
and something's going on that is
bothering you and making you feel like
you're being smothered or sort of your
space is being pinched a bit
and so just
bring it up with him and be like
can't you guys like go to her place or
something like this is kind of annoying
the second thing he said concerns me a
bit more what do you think he means by
the way yeah like he's not beating
himself i don't know i i got the sense
that then he said not taking care of
himself yeah though that's that maybe he
just meant like he's like
uh
his friend is like
not obsessing but like letting his other
priorities
fall by the wayside because he's in love
you know if it's a new relationship it
might even out though dude you know what
i mean like
yeah yeah loves someone it's like
[ __ ]
the whole time and then yeah but uh yeah
i i think that uh you bring it up but i
also think that you know if he's
encroaching boundaries then [ __ ] you
got to do the same bro it's all that
working yeah in an apartment dude it
looked like an apartment it was yeah
okay well all that warfare yeah all that
warfare and what does that mean to you
uh you walk around with a towel on you
you know you pop in you sometimes
they're [ __ ] and you know and you
open the door like you're trying to get
oh i'm sorry i had no idea you know what
i mean sorry but you know
you're always here and it's just
anyway i'm gonna grab toothpicks or walk
around without a towel on that is yeah
it is your house it's your [ __ ] house
it's not starbucks that's what you
should do do [ __ ] that's like
borderline if you if you were to have
guests yeah but then if it's like and
then the roommate or or his partner
could just be like hey why are you yeah
walking around with no pants like i'm
home oh you know what the perfect it's
not my guest i'm home
that's great but you know what the
perfect thing is you know that thing
that people do in the backyard or on
their patio where they [ __ ]
they they let the sun in their anus
where they fall oh yeah oh yeah put
their chest on the ground oh yeah do
that a lot yeah
receive the sun in your anus yeah and
when and don't draw the blind let them
see out into the [ __ ] patio if it's
an apartment even better dude yeah
there's just like a little patio and
he's just out there trying to receive
the sun with his anus yeah dude and that
uh will very quickly
you'll have way more of a boundary
because they won't be there a lot i
think that that's great receive the sun
with your anus on on that note i
actually knew a guy who
put it was he went on craigslist and for
three dollars he would allow people to
come over
and
stick their ass toward the sun on his
property and have the sun pour
into uh their anus on his property for
three dollars seems like it should be
more than that but what i'm saying is
free regardless of the price he should
start doing that
and then when the roommate complains
yeah and the roommate complains just be
like
well you always have your partner over
i'm just trying to these are my sun
receivers these are my friends yeah i
make a little money on your side this
way oh you don't like it okay well then
let's talk about etiquette well i made
nine dollars how much and how much did
your [ __ ] break that's going towards
rent yeah right right right yeah
um he also would charge five dollars if
they wanted to come [ __ ] in his yard
hmm so it's it's definitely sexual
because he's not
charging enough you know he's not not
even close to enough yeah
no
no dude i'll take your dick for a dollar
those things
those things uh should both require
more money wow dude i've done it done
which one
receiving the sun with my anus oh yeah
me too it feels amazing yeah it does it
really really oddly feels amazing yeah
it does to take your pants off
offer the sun your anus
get the right direction
to the sun and you feel so warm yeah
it like warms your whole body yeah it's
crazy weird
yeah it's like it's the sun sneaks into
your butt and warms you from the inside
i also have [ __ ] in my friend's uh uh
yard well i've [ __ ] in so many yards oh
okay well don't one-up me like that all
right i'm the yard [ __ ] yeah
on the way to see eminem i shouldn't and
[ __ ] someone yeah
no not his oh oh yeah i remember that
yeah yeah i mean [ __ ] it was brutal
dude i've told him plenty of times on
podcasts but it sounds brutal yeah the
[ __ ] worse with the drive oh [ __ ]
guy i still get mad about it the driver
that was driving us i was like you gotta
pull off right now i gotta go to the
bathroom dude and he pulls off he was
gonna go right or left there's a
hospital to the right an open road to
the left he turns red he turns left
and i was like okay well you got to pull
over now i'm using the yard yeah i mean
it was imminent dude yeah mountain lion
open road you mean what just like
houses and too many things like what
about where are we going oh it's a
[ __ ] hospital like a residential
street
even if i [ __ ] my pants on the way into
the hospital i'll be we'll be able to
clean up they have all supplies and they
won't get arrested
yeah yeah anyway
all right let's do the next one yeah
hey chris and matt i absolutely love the
show it's hilarious it's probably one of
the only shows that i listen to that
i'll actually laugh out loud from oh
yeah um but i have a nine month old baby
she's amazing in every way we love her
so much um but my husband and i are at a
point where we're like okay she's going
to be our first and our last baby
um are we going to have another baby or
you know are we going to be one and done
um you know kind of don't want to go
through the newborn phase all over again
and kind of start from scratch um we're
finally like starting to get our life
back on track yeah um so i wanted to ask
you guys you know do you think it's
important to have a sibling in your life
or you know what are the
cons of being an only child i already
we're already getting the comments from
people saying oh you know she would be
so lonely or she'd be spoiled and you
know she'd resent you guys you know in
the future or whatever
um
i think there's tons of perks to being
an only child but then i see your guys
relationship and i think you guys
balance each other out super well and
you guys obviously have a great
relationship so i wanted to see what you
guys thought you know
are we being selfish for not giving her
a sibling or you know for her to be an
only child what do you think thanks i
mean not being selfish you're absolutely
not being if you don't want to have
another kid don't ever do yeah do not
listen to people who are like they're
going to be that uh what the [ __ ] yeah
do other people know about what your
kid's going to be like yeah do what you
want to do do not get pressured into
having another [ __ ] yeah if the one
kid sure feels right then that is right
period the end your kid's gonna be
[ __ ] fine if you love
her is it a boy or girl i forget i died
i don't think i said anyway yeah your
kid's gonna be [ __ ] fine if you're
good parents it doesn't matter how many
siblings they have they could have zero
or five um i what if at the end of that
you i looked over to you and you were in
tears looking at me um i think that i
think that so here's what i think yeah i
agree 100 with you there
it's so funny that she's like our life
is getting back on track dude that's
biology man this is biology and i'm
gonna [ __ ] tell you this right now
and this is crazy because this is what's
happened to [ __ ] chris this is what
happens to pregnant
people like the ladies and [ __ ] uh
you because kristen like she did not
like some some women like pregnancy you
know they they love it they think it's
it's great they seem so crazy to me they
get catered to they feel nurturing you
know
and um
and uh
kristen was just like i can't wait for
this to just be done right i feel like i
remember that yeah and so
calvin came out and he and she was like
uh
i can't i i i know i want to have more
kids but oh my gosh right i don't know
right right i remember that for sure as
the months progressed
it was just still no no no no no no and
then once they get to be
two or something like that
three four you for you literally i was
reading about this biology makes you
forget about that
so you'll have more kids yeah i don't
know how [ __ ]
uh true it is because it was an fhm
magazine but
that makes sense we are wired we are
wired to just produce produce people
more people but yeah so so here's my
point is that's pro that is i feel like
likely gonna happen to you it seems like
she's
a very sweet kind of nurturing
seems like she's a good mom to a
nine-month-old right if she's being
thought very thoughtful right yeah so
but um
here's another thing that i think
and i was talking to my friend michael
batz who's a [ __ ] talented comedian i
saw him at eric griffin's wedding and he
was like dude
if you want number two
do it
soon
do it soon don't wait he was like think
about
in the future when they're 13 and 10 or
13 and 11
think about the life you want
think about what you want and and do it
soon if that's what you want and that
was a really good piece of advice that
he told me because i
i never really thought of it that way i
just thought do it when
you
feel like you want to do it again well
that's what i think so tell me why i'm
wrong because
we're three and a half years apart
i love that we're not too far apart yeah
and we're not you know closer would have
been fine i feel like but um
i just feel like
if you have a 12 year old and a six year
old that's totally fine but it's a it's
a different thing than having siblings
that are right next to each other and if
that's the life you want fine but if you
want more and you want the siblings with
what she's talking about to have that
connection i think doing it sooner is
better
i don't think she should have another
kid well i mean maybe she shouldn't but
i'm just saying if she if she wants to
what she said about we're finally just
now getting our life back is sticking in
my head and i feel like that's how the
thing starts what i first said
what what do you mean
that's how the thing starts we finally
get our life back and then okay good our
life's back and then oh i want another
kid
um well it's a slow thing but if that's
the case if that's where she arrives
then obviously they should have another
kid but it
just go off of whatever the [ __ ] is in
front of you and in your own mind do not
go off of what
other people
what is with other people other people
yeah but the fact that she's saying we
just got our life back together we don't
know it means that that's gonna happen
to her like when you ask people who only
want one kid who have one kid after
you're gonna have more they go no one
and done yeah
i just i i just think that that's where
she's swaying yeah that's all and i'm
sorry to not make this utterly [ __ ]
hilarious but sometimes you gotta get
real
yeah you gotta you know me dude
sometimes you got to be super real yeah
sometimes you've got to be super real
right
upside down head ah wait wait we know
this guy hey man chris this is cory from
missouri calling in again uh i don't
know if you guys necessarily want people
to like update on past calls yeah you
like that but i just thought i'd throw
it out there we'll find out because uh
since my last submission that you guys
put on the show thank you for that by
the way somebody oh yeah crazy [ __ ] has
happened the kid oh the kids oh right if
you recall it was about uh my
girlfriend's mom yeah trying to
undermine our parenting and taking
family and all that stuff
and you're right you had a good point
that the term uh
toxic can get thrown around a lot and
doesn't necessarily carry a lot of
weight sometimes but let me paint a
picture for you so
uh since my last call
her mom
made up some [ __ ] about her being
addicted to pills and suicidal and all
this stuff that was completely untrue
and uh used it to manage to get her
committed to a mental facility on an
involuntary hold cops showed up at the
house and took her away from her kids
and while she was in there for two days
it was supposed to be four but they
released her after two because it was
clear she wasn't supposed to be in there
while that was going on her mom also got
a restraining order against her
and emergency guardianship of the girls
claiming that she's trying to help her
and that she
isn't fit as a mother which is
completely untrue and this judge just
signed off on all of it
and
now we don't have the kids
and so now we're having to get a lawyer
and jump through all these hoops and
legal loopholes and [ __ ] just to try to
get our family back together at home
where it belongs
it's absolutely bonkers to me that
someone
could be so
evil against their own family
and think that
they should be in control of everything
when it has nothing to do with her
and so the reason i'm updating you guys
is
you know we're taking the steps doing
everything we can to get them back
um and she's handling it like an
absolute champ but in the meantime i
guess the advice i want now is uh
how do i
frame this in my mind how do i handle
the stress of this day in and day out
when i still have to go to work and
there's nothing we can do on the
weekends and the legal process is so
slow and and and now i'm just rambling
and i understand if you need to cut this
short or if it doesn't make it but i
just had to
i just thought you guys might want to
know so uh where where do we even go
from here
thank you guys for doing this show it's
awesome i appreciate you uh doing what
you're doing
and more power to you hope to see you
live sometime chris maybe if you come
down to missouri we'll see i'll be there
but anyway have a great one um dude
sometimes they're just cory dude [ __ ]
man whoa so hold on sometimes there are
just villains in the world dude
sometimes there are actual real
villains in the world whether it's
mental [ __ ] uh imbalance some kind of
chemical imbalance that this woman has
or whatever the [ __ ] i don't know but
that is just an actual villain person
there's no villains it's that is a
villain dude she thinks she's doing the
right thing that doesn't make her a
non-villain
yeah but
i mean okay so let me get this straight
the the mom called
to get the daughter
in a mental hospital correct
and then she was released in two days
correct but she still has custody of the
kids because of this in those two days
she got an emergency right uh i forgot
what the word is yeah yeah but emergency
so
guardianship of okay so and then does
she still have so now they have the kids
no now the mom has the kid the mom the
grandma has the kids the grandma has the
kids yes still yes
that's what i'm saying sometimes there's
villains dude well you just and
eventually you will win but don't do
anything [ __ ] stupid because as you
say the the law moves really [ __ ]
slow eventually you will
your wife will get the kids i know but
there's nothing he can do besides do the
thing that you have to do he's the same
one his wife is the same one keep doing
the [ __ ] things you got to do
legally properly and eventually you will
get the kids back it's terrible but
sometimes in this world you gotta you
gotta live with the fact that there are
real [ __ ] villains out there who will
be
villainous and it will [ __ ] ruin your
life
the the
honestly
this is just the [ __ ] that you have to
deal with right now and it sucks yeah
right so
sometimes you just have to say that
it'll be over
you just gotta
keep showing up keep going to work keep
going back keep trying to see the kids
keep being with your wife or whatever it
is baby mom and um
that is just insane man my heart goes
out to you dude that is such something
that just doesn't need to happen and we
did say toxic is something you throw
around but this sounds like maybe it's a
good fit i mean this is crazy dude
wild piece of [ __ ] the other advice i
would give you i know you're heavily
involved and you love these kids and you
[ __ ] hate this woman as you have
every right to do but imagine the
position and i'm sure you have the
position that you're that your wife is
in or whether it's fiance or wife or
whatever
it is happening to you but even more
than it's happening to you it's
happening to her dude you gotta [ __ ]
be there in every possible way for her
we're talking last time he called in he
was talking about how do i be the father
to her kids that uh
mom and stuff
this is how you do it dude you'll be
there when it matters the absolute most
and nothing could possibly matter
more right now and to go off of what
you're saying here's a chance you have
yeah these kids are young here's a
chance you have to show up for them in
the right way
and to when they get older and when you
explain everything that went down they
know that you were doing the right thing
and that you were being a good guy so in
a way this is a gift
yes dude reframing i've been trying to
learn reframing through therapy and [ __ ]
yeah and the other thing about there
being villains in the world is that that
means they also can be [ __ ] heroes so
you get to be a hero right now i mean so
if you want to reframe it then there you
go but i'm telling you dude just keep
doing the things legally that you have
to do keep going down that path because
you don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] up or
upend anything that is going in your
direction you're eventually going to get
it to go your way but there are crazy
people out there who say crazy [ __ ] you
tell crazy [ __ ] lies
and you're dealing with one right now
just saw
just saw batman you know
just saw that i never saw you can't stop
talking about villains so what do you
think about that what do you think about
that i never saw it what do you think
about that well it's been out for months
what do you think about that there's
something you never saw it you say i
haven't what do you think about that
though i'm telling you oh okay
hi chris and matt my name is maddie and
the issue that i could use some advice
with is that i hold all of my value in
what other people say about me so i
don't think too highly of myself i need
constant like assurance that i am doing
a good job that i am on the right path
in life
so that kind of leads to me being like
this big people pleaser and not really
knowing
how to act around these people
that i'm supposedly friends with so
i won't get into too much detail because
that is for me and my therapist to talk
about but i was kind of curious as to
what you guys say and how you think that
i could authentically be myself which is
something that you guys talk about a lot
on your podcast so just let me know what
you guys think
you know i i dude i
what is
what a question i i do talk about that a
lot of my my podcast things as life
moves on things become more important
things become less important and it's
hard for me
i i realize that i do hold weight in
that as well like i do care a lot about
what other people think and um
i don't uh
i don't really like that about myself i
i always go to the negative like i think
i have this [ __ ] problem i walk into
a room i think it happened the other day
i walked into this place i'm like oh
that person probably hates me and they
came up and they're like hey man i love
your [ __ ] he's a big fan and i'm like
dude i gotta drop this [ __ ] right
and and and and the point is um
like my therapist told me once she was
like do you love calvin and i said yeah
and she said why and she said
i said i don't know just because and he
was like exactly
he's like he just he's him let him be
him he's you know he doesn't have to be
anything you don't have to be anything
for people to like you she's sweet as
[ __ ] yeah i mean she's such a sweetheart
and i i understand that want dude i'm a
comedian
you know i'm a comedian and a [ __ ]
addict like i look for it everywhere i
want people to like me because i don't
feel
[ __ ] i don't feel
good a lot you know these walls that
i've built up
over the years
being on stage and [ __ ] yelling at
people
having convincing them to like me and
and and like trying to like
you know
uh
just like
get girls and women to like me it's just
like it just
it just it's it you gotta you gotta drop
that and it's so hard and i'm glad
you're in therapy because
you know dropping those walls for me was
a big thing and it's hard and it's a
struggle the whole time i mean i still
i'm 42 you're much younger than me but
i'm 42 and um
it's [ __ ] hard to
it's hard to be authentically you
because you lie
to yourself a lot and and and it's hard
to even know who you truly are at least
for me and
i do a lot of [ __ ]
thinking about that a lot of
soul searching and i can't do it all the
time and i get caught up and i i i want
people to like me and then i realize i
have my family i don't need that i have
you you know what i mean
i don't know how do you feel about this
[ __ ] i think two things one you don't we
don't really control who we are or what
we are the ways that we are as much as
we think we do in fact we don't at all
we are the way that we are so for even
you to have a judgment on that is
utterly pointless but for other people
to have a judgment on it is even more
[ __ ] pointless you just are the way
that you are and yes you can control
your actions
so to speak and like you don't have to
do the bad thing you can stop yourself
from doing something bad to yourself or
to others but that doesn't that's not
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
the way that you are
nobody did that you didn't design that
that just is the way it is that's the
first part second part is everyone's
dealing with the same [ __ ] thing
everyone's going through a version of
what you're describing and so the
realization that i think for me when i
go through these things i get so deep
down in the whole of that the whole that
is my own mind but everybody's going
through a version of it as well so the
fact that you're kind of doing this
thing
you feel like you're doing it on your
own in a sense you are because there's
only one you and that is you but
everyone is doing their own version of
it so you're in it
along with everybody else and there's
this sort of like
feeling of unity and this feeling it's
like less dramatic and severe when you
can sit back and realize oh wait
everybody's in the same position
everybody in this entire [ __ ] room or
this entire setting or whatever the [ __ ]
is thinking about
uh
did i do that right did i do that did i
do this other thing right does that
person hate me does this person like me
uh do i look [ __ ] stupid right now
did i just sound stupid when i said that
the whole [ __ ] thing everybody's
doing it and you know the people that
aren't doing that tend to be [ __ ]
sociopaths so like you're you're doing
it right don't worry though about uh
any kind of the extraneous [ __ ]
everyone's going through what you're
going through their own version of it
and that to me is this sort of like
freeing thing that sort of gets me out
of the hole that is my mind um yeah and
other people's opinion on you
uh that's none of your [ __ ] business
that's a saying that i like to try and
remember um did john lennon say that no
no it's like a [ __ ] addict thing oh
um but yeah so that's what's up
uh yeah so that's good we kind of ended
on not a funny did you ever see blue
chips um i have some great tips i
thought
yep i saw him a sheep uh
all right well let me just plug my dates
now that i'm gonna be in grand prairie
texas i'm gonna be in dallas uh so
that's gonna be great tickets are are
there uh chrisleya.com dallas is grand
prairie dallas uh wichita kansas those
are some new dates i just added so go
get tickets now atlanta georgia
september 9th washington dc i got a lot
of dates coming up stockton california
oakland california peoria illinois
rockford illinois raleigh north carolina
october 21st i'll be in savannah which
is where that guy or that no the boy was
a woman that uh oh yeah the woman that
asked to be
interesting yeah uh denver colorado
november 5th cheyenne wyoming boston two
shows at the wang november 12th lakeland
florida that's a new one in jacksonville
florida uh at the morin theater on
december 3rd and uh
super cult this is something that we
didn't talk about that's the new uh
that's the new um
uh stu studios here and uh be ready for
some more content you know we got this
podcast we got congratulations on the uh
this new channel name too right i didn't
know what the new channel name it's the
new channel name yeah yeah yeah um so
uh
subscribe to us and there'll be more
content coming we've got other shows
coming up uh and if you have a question
sent in a video
in the link in the description below or
go to watchlifeline.com
thank you very much
thank you on your ass
[Music]